in Britain we love Thai food and I've
come to Thailand to learn how to cook it
the authentic way 20 years ago we have
good old-fashioned English pubs serving
Thai food love it absolutely adore it
I want to learn how type people cook
their recipes I'm heading north
renowned for hot and aromatic dishes
it's the perfect place to learn to cook
Thailand's famous spicy food my key to
the north Huy
she runs a famous cookery school here
and she's the auricle on this region's
dishes
so where we going now I'm taking you to
the house of the lady who make a very
good sausage is there not unties I said
risk our sidewalks agua yeah
mrs. rod has been selling a spicy
sausage from her doorstep for the past
20 years
pleasure meeting you and these are them
yes that is Wow
I'm missing where she makes the sausages
yeah the legendary sausages I'd love to
taste them spicy face spicy is a spicy
sausage very good very good indeed
delicious she's definitely the sausage
Queen they're hot they're as hot as a
furnace but the flavor is incredible I
want to know mrs. rods secret when is
she making the next batch I would love
for you just show me how to make these
she does not look very happy
she was been denounced for them or
generally she wants me to Dallas I've
gotta for Delia's heart well I'm a latke
and you're gonna sit in your country no
I wouldn't sell the sausages at home my
god no no no no I'd be shot if they're
that spicy deal mmm yeah we're gonna
make a sausage let's go after intense
negotiations misses the rod reveals her
secret a grinder in a backyard where she
makes a spicy paste right where do I
start up my dad's car she did she's
using hundreds of powerful Thai chilies
[Music]
she adds in shallots and garlic so she's
not weigh anything out and then to give
it that distinctive flavor she adds
classic Thai herbs
that's just slice lemongrass yeah
mortuary all of that so tumor it's
giving that really nice vibrant color
and that's the minced pork just squeezes
squeezing man that's all the ingredients
ground and mixed now for the tricky part
[Music]
okay
it's fiddly work
I'm mrs. Rudd thinks that apprentice
needs more practice trust me with
sausage wasn't out he's got off to a tee
I'm calling you tonight
but mrs. Rudd wants a favor in return
for her recipe she wants my help
catering for a special house party
tomorrow you have to come and help her
you can have the house blessing tomorrow
morning she'll be very upset if tomorrow
you don't come and help her because
you're he gave her her recipe trust me
yeah I would definitely be here tomorrow
morning on time to help her okay good
nice forget the kiss and maybe tomorrow